Some signs of progress
after a devastating three way train crash
rocked India over the weekend.
Crews have now cleared the rails,
allowing other trains to pass
through the crash site.
It is one of the deadliest
India has ever seen.
Nearly 300 people were killed,
more than a thousand injured.
We want to take you now
live to the scene
in Eastern
India with CNN's
Ivan Watson, who's there for us.
Ivan,
how exactly does
something like this happen?
The authorities are saying
this was some kind of a
switching malfunction.
That result resulted.
Boris in this kind of perfect storm
of a train crash
with a staggering loss of lives.
The trains have started running again
through this area.
Because the work crews have been working
feverishly there.
But dozens of victims, their bodies
have yet to be identified.
Working on the railroad
an army of laborers
laying new rail by hand,
racing to reopen this transport route
after one of the deadliest
train disasters
India has seen in its modern history.
On Friday night, three trains
collided in this area and everywhere
on the side of the tracks.
In this rural part of eastern India,
there are massive railroad cars
that were well,
as you can see,
severely damaged in this collision.
This vehicle here, this car was reserved
for people with disabilities.
You can still see people's
personal belongings
down below, right outside.
It began with a passenger train
moving at 128 kilometers or 80 miles
per hour,
slamming into a parked freight train
colliding after dark in this rural area.
Villagers rescued passengers.